14 pounds of beef 10 pounds of dough 6
pounds of cheese this burger is gonna be
56 times the size of a regular burger
hey guys my name is alvin i'm a tasty
producer and i love making crazy food
and my friend victor actually hit me up
yesterday and he is the guy that just
loves burgers to the end of the world
and he goes i got a favorite ass you
know i like burgers right well you see
my birthday is coming up real soon and i
don't really like cake i was wondering
could you make me a giant cheeseburger
for my birthday but i was like dang
okay i see you all right hit me up
tomorrow and see what i can do thanks
man you're the goat
what's up dude how's it going you good
what you got for me grabbed a couple of
my favorite burgers i want you to come
check it out what do you love so much
about this burger it starts off with
this amazing toasted brioche bun
toasting it on both sides to make sure
it's crispy
and the beef the way that they sear it
the juiciness
banging and that cheese
that cheese though it melts into all the
little crevices of the beef that's what
i'm talking about and the toppings are
super simple lettuce tomato oh man once
you put all those wonderful things
together you take that bite
[Music]
amazing so i'm gonna
try to make you a really big version of
this it might not be easy but i'm gonna
see what i can do if anybody can do it
as you man all right thanks dude
appreciate it
time to make this crazy thing we're
gonna start with his giant custom
brioche bun pretty classic kriosh recipe
some flour some salt sugar a couple of
eggs
gonna get this started
i forgot the dough hook while this is
going i'm gonna make the starter mixture
a cup of water yeast some milk for the
yeast to drink kind of get hydrated
start drinking and start growing because
you know this eats ain't hit puberty yet
five to eight minutes low speed until
the dough comes together and then we're
gonna add a lot of butter
the dough is coming together it's in a
ball shape brioche one of the most
signature things is a lot of butter so
add it slowly incorporate into the dough
and kind of make it super velvety oh
that's looking hot hot isn't good
there we go a lot of dough
y'all that's nice
cool
so yeah shape it to a ball
get this guy into this buttered
dish bed get some plastic wrap cover
this guy up
let him take a nap for two hours and
i'll see you in a bit dude so while the
dough rests i want to use some foil to
kind of make the bun stay in this tape
[Music]
where's the halfway point for this 12
and a half again gotta make a circle
clasp it together this sort of thing
this is a big ass circle hope it's dirty
you have to hold the bread but we'll see
oh
man this is a big boy right here
[Music]
here we go
so satisfying oh
[Music]
wow maybe i should have oiled my surface
get the air bubbles out reshape it into
the form of a circle for the hamburger
bun so the recipe for this dough
actually makes 10 individual buns and i
doubled the recipe so this bun is
actually going to be the size of 20 buns
i think i'm going to put some egg wash
on this off to the oven you go we'll see
you in a minute
[Music]
this is a big bun
[Music]
that is a burger bun
then directly
into the pan looking pretty good well
this one kind of toasts in the pan i'm
just gonna brush some butter on this
gonna throw it in the boil over there to
get toasted too oh that's a nice toast
now we're gonna make this beef patty i
got the biggest tray we could find in
the kitchen i got a lot of beef but not
with a lot of people and it is 14 pounds
of beef and an average burger somewhere
around a quarter pound this burger is
gonna be 56 times a regular burger oh
wait gloves
let's get to work
i don't think i've ever seen this much
meat in my life you know when i went to
the grocery store to get this the lady
in line behind me was like boy you
hungry
and i was like
you bet i am a visual representation
between machine gun kelly and eminem m
alright that's all the beef it's like
working with dough but not really
because the dough is meat time to season
garlic powder onion powder smoked
paprika a lot of pepper make it rain boy
like almost like a quarter cup of salt
don't be afraid to season your meat
y'all oh wait i need to take my watch
out before this get any crazier and to
make it all evenly combined
it's a lot harder than i thought it was
gonna be i think i've seen salt bae
through some of these videos getting
tired thing is wild never was the
trainer like hey here's a 14 pounds of
ground meat do five reps
all right it's been seven years let's
say this meat is thoroughly mixed and
figure out how to get it into a patty
shape second pan please thanks brenda
appreciate it
this is one patty
this is the second one we're gonna make
it into a perfect circle outside's
thicker than inside because when a
burger cooks it actually shrinks
that's a meat pizza
that's one all right let's go for
another one i'm changing to a slapping
technique this is how you train as a
masseuse
i don't have a pan that can sear so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to put them
in the oven 300 degrees to kind of cook
them all through and then i turn on the
broiler really nice caramelization on
top to get all the flavor the patties
are done i need to deal with the cheese
though
[Music]
so we're gonna make the big cheese slice
now a lot of people might be saying hey
why don't you just put a bunch of cheese
slices on top of the patty itself i mean
you could but we're at tasty we're
making it big so why not just make a
giant cheese slice
oh
a piece filled half american cheese half
cheddar cheese let it cook down let it
melt a little bit if you are lactose
intolerant
look away now we about to go in that's
some good cheese right there oh my
oh my ma look at this all right we gotta
work fast before it starts to get cold
this also may or may not be too much
cheese but there's no such thing as too
much cheese where's that spatula one
last smooth these cheese slices gonna go
in the fridge
see you in a bit oh that's hot oh my
goodness that's so hot
so these cheese slices have firmed up
pretty nicely put these
on here
trim these up a bit uh save these snacks
for later
looking good
you know sometimes i dream of crazy
things this is how cheese slices are
made
was pretty good i made my own custom
cheese slice these are the biggest
cutting boards i've ever seen i didn't
even know we had stuff this big
so we're gonna see if this actually
works
okay i think that's pretty cool i may
have overestimated how much cheese i
needed but
there's nothing wrong with more cheese
i'm gonna put these back in the oven
until they're nice and really delicious
and we're gonna build this burger oh
this just got so much heavier i will see
you when you are nice and melted bye-bye
oh my gosh my breath that
is what i like to see
i think it looks great i just kind of
want to eat it right now but i can't
because victor's got to eat it buns are
toasted garnishes are ready burger's
ready patty's ready i think it's time to
build this burger i'm actually pretty
nervous for it there's like 14 pounds of
beef 10 pounds of dough 6 pounds of
cheese here we go all right big
paddy goes
yes
patty number two is landed i think the
bun might be a little too small but
that's okay
there it is
oh this is looking cool nice floral
arrangement seeing this come together i
think you could probably fit a piece of
this in your mouth nice
bed of lettuce tomatoes how's that song
go i got beans greens tomatoes potatoes
yams something one
and a two and a three
time to do the top bun in the sauce this
is some secret burger sauce i've made
mayo some mustard some ketchup some
pickle juice that's pretty much it
take this toasted burger bun then just
kind of spread it nice and evenly over
it all right here we go gotta put the
cat on the hat this might not be a big
enough hat come on
okay the top of the bun shrunk a little
bit more than i thought it was going to
uh but that's okay this burger is pretty
much done i'm going to go get victor
it's his birthday today i really want to
know if it actually tastes good so i'm
going to wash my hands and we're going
to go surprisingly
this is like 25 pounds what's up vic
what's up alvin this is the size of a
regular burger correct yes sir close
your eyes awesome i can't wait
wow why did that sound like that ready
ready man one two
three open your eyes vic
oh
my goodness bro
what amazing bro it's like the same
thing but just big right huge
how many burgers do you think would fit
in this if i put like 20 of those
burgers in here easy the first thing i
thought of was just how beautiful it
looks unbelievable let's bite into this
bad boy i can't wait to try it man i
really can't wait to try it oh
that's a thick burger
with two seeds maybe three oh my god
that's a proper serving size
[Music]
that's what i'm talking about how do you
get it to be so juicy he toasted the you
toasted the buns bro we're not wasting
any of this i think i'm gonna have to
call down some friends bro all right
let's bring in the bathtub
feeding a lot of my friends with this
giant burger and just watching them
finish it all it really made me happy
granny and the bun might have been a
little small the cheese a little too
thick this time
but seeing people smile and being able
to make them happy with food that is the
best feeling in the world for me so if
you got a favorite food comment below
hit me up send me a dm and i will do my
very best to try and make a big cream
until then
[Music]
you